one thing people need to realize is that
we're in a low period with the election
for the president was last year there's
no real cycle right now this year's
everyone kind of just like is exhausted
2022 is the midterms 2023 is the
presidential primary cycle followed by
24 the presidential cycle and that is
going to be ramping up worse absolutely
more extreme than we saw but I do want
to show this story real quick and the
story itself I think is important I
don't think it's the most excitable
story it's from NBC all children should
wear masks in school this fall even if
vaccinated according to pediatrics group
The American Academy of Pediatrics is
calling the new guidance a layered
approach we had Steve Bannon on the show
nice he said on August 15th when mothers
start learning about what their children
are being taught there is going to be
you know a Ruckus or there's gonna it's
gonna I don't know I don't know the
exact word but you know you get the
points like yeah people are going to
lose it and he's right I think a lot of
the critical race Theory stuff is going
to result in moms being shocked and
angered but this is already happening
yeah absolutely absolutely now consider
when kids are back in school summer ends
I saw this story and I saw it on Reddit
and I looked at the comments because the
first thing I thought when I saw that
they were that schools wanted to make
kids wear wear masks even if they're
vaccinated my immediate thought was
there was no way even the establishment
leftists the people who march on a dime
for the for the establishment are going
to be okay with this because even though
we have seen two Great Lengths these
people are willing to contort themselves
this will snap their brains like a
rubber band and I was right surprisingly
the top comments on Reddit which is
mostly leftists were like I can't do
this anymore I can't handle this one
response was I'm a high school teacher
this is insane I will not be the Mass
police I can't handle this and it was
just inundated people saying this is
nuts it's gone too far we're losing
control but the funny thing is they were
trying to adhere to the narrative like
we have to do it but their brains were
just at that point where the rubber band
was gonna snap seeing the person say I'm
a high school teacher and I just can't
handle it
anymore and I'm like whether they want
to support the narrative or not the
rubber band is going to snap back and
then something's gonna happen I don't
know what yep maybe it actually
stabilizes things I see a lot of Doom
posting on Twitter from My Tribe talking
about oh gosh you know the left is going
further on this and this and you know
the 1984 totalitarian blah blah blah
we're all doomed and it's all over and
linear uh extrapolations I think are
always naive and wrong because there are
feedback loops and um you know as stuff
gets crazier more and more people start
saying I you know I can't buy into this
anymore and I I think that we are
rapidly approaching that point the
cathedral or the you know political
organization right now has this plan
that has worked for them and it's worked
for 20 or 30 or 40 years which is you
bang more and more about racism and it
motivates the base and it gets people
out to March and it motivates donations
and you know they did this for all four
years of trump
and you know there's a terrible thing I
mean it's hilarious but it's also
terrible which is that the word racist
and the word Nazi have lost all power
because you know racism is a terrible
thing and no one wants to be you know
called a racist if it's meaningful and
Nazis are you know the second worst uh
political thing after communism and uh
you know that's terrible and no one
wants to be called a Nazi and so at
first they're saying you know okay these
literal Nazis marching down the streets
are Nazis they're like yes they are
they're saying terrible things about
Jews you know that's terrible and then
next they're saying you know this guy
who's not a Nazi but he's got some you
know really bad opinions as a Nazi
you're like yeah okay I guess that's
pretty nazi-like and then pretty soon
you know my half-nigerian friend Fred is
not see I'm like I a he's not a Nazi and
B that word is now entirely meaningless
it doesn't matter anymore right right
it's not about the word being
meaningless the word can mean whatever
it wants I just don't care right that's
that's what I'm saying I've done
something amazing when half the
population doesn't care it's not about
half the population it's not half the
population I don't care about what these
left this Ray jubate smear Merchants
care for the same reason I don't care
about what people in Liberia are saying
about me it's a different country and it
has nothing to do with me right so when
I see these people who I know live in
Wally World and believe nonsical garbage
I'm like they can say whatever they want
I'm over it yep I don't view them as the
look The Divide in this country has has
grown so great right there's two
countries that it's more than that it's
beyond a shatter and there's all these
different fractals it is Beyond two
countries it is Beyond two countries
when I heard this is the example I use
every time Joe Biden talking about
lockdowns when red states were doing the
opposite I was like that's it it is very
clear that he does not view us as part
of the conversation or as part of the
country or as someone who needs to be
talked to so when I see someone in the
mainstream media and NBC or whatever say
something I'm like why do I care what
they think yep it is not part of the
world I live in and and I didn't start
it I'm just responding to it absolutely
my friend Adam uh said something really
interesting I'm under or two back which
is you know I think his exact words were
I'm really realizing more and more that
I'm a patriot of com of a country that
never really existed and I think you
know if you look at Twitter and other
places people on the right are saying
you know effectively I don't know what I
believe in I you know believe in this
1950s world but also the 1950s world was
maybe more an uh artifact of marketing
than reality oh yeah and people on the
left you know they March but then the
world isn't operating the way they think
it's supposed to operate and their
models are broken there's a huge
cultural laser on Wii or something going
on because all of the old explanations
and answers have broken down and uh you
know Joe Biden isn't motivating anyone
there's no narratives that are
motivating anyone and uh we're
discovering the new world right now it's
true Matt we ended slavery but China
didn't and we buy products from China
right that are getting made by slaves so
we're basically still supporting slavery
yeah no I mean we have companies that
you've you've that have used Sweatshop
labor foreign
like in the it is blatant structure in
the economy and I'll tell you this
because at Occupy Wall Street they had a
memorial for Steve Jobs that to me was
the funniest things now it's not like
it's not like the people of occupy all
came together and voted here here we all
agree but many people there set up a
memorial because he died in October of
2011. and I was laughing it's just like
the absurdity of one of the most
ruthless Cutthroat capitalist
businessmen who exploited Chinese
Communist slave labor it's being propped
up by these people at occupy and I was
there and I'm just like
and you know what I I I I've long known
because I worked at nonprofits that it's
it's all marketing it's all PR it's all
it's all an attempt to gain support but
I think what happens is the internet
allows for you know we used to have five
TV channels or whatever three if you're
older yeah three right yeah and everyone
just agreed with like the narrative
coming from these channels the Overton
window was an inch wide that's right now
with the internet the Overton window
extends for the most part from like the
center right to the far left it's kind
of hilarious that that's true the
mainstream will allow these
conversations they'll wag their finger
at the center right right right
but but anyway the main point is that it
allows the entirety of the political
Compass to exist now in the space even
if we can say the Overton window doesn't
include the far right the authoritarian
right and even and for some reason and
caps get lumped in there sometimes I
mean I I think the uh Overton window
includes uh just enough Republicans that
they they the cathedral or they the um
you know sort of central political
organization you can say oh we're
tolerant we accept everyone up to John
McCain and you know maybe Mitt Romney on
a good day but regardless of what the
cathedral Cathedral thinks there are
online communities for literally every
absolutely and it's glorious I love it
yeah yeah I mean it used to be
um much much harder it was much more
centralized more of a now it's it's
evened out quite a bit but I do think
this is causing a lot of our problems
especially when you know so we're seeing
this shuffling this this great sorting
algorithm is kind of happening West
Virginia is losing residence right and
one of the stories I read was about a
teacher and she gave an interview and
she was like what they're doing to the
unions and how they treat us as absurd
and the state is racist so I'm leaving
I'm going to Austin or something like
that or you know some other city and I'm
like isn't it fascinating that in the in
one of the West Virginia I think is the
second most Trump supporting state from
2020 and you have the people who are
Democrats outraged and leaving meanwhile
you have the more conservative types
from cities outraged and leaving right
everything's being sorted it's almost
like we're in this big um you know sieve
or whatever and it's being you know
they're shaking it and some are falling
through and some aren't yeah so I I
wonder the fascinating thing about this
is
you know we I've talked about Civil War
quite a bit and right now we have this
poll showing the bulk potential
balkanization it's I did the math 37.2
percent of the population is in favor of
their region balkanizing you know
Southern ad is a real Centrist
Republican uh you know sort of Mitt
Romney Republican and I had the pleasure
of seeing my folks uh over this past
weekend after a year and a half because
of covid and my dad this sort of you
know mainstream whatever media TV is
telling me you know he's talking about
you know we need to break into two
countries and when you're looking at you
know 75 year old Boomers who came up in
the system and they're saying you know
they're sending like some crazy new
reactionary on Twitter uh man the
world's gotten strange but it's not
neo-reactionary it's 47 of Democrats on
the west coast so what we're seeing with
this with separation is I'm not actually
convinced it's going to just be you know
so so one thing I've said recently is
that I think we're more likely to break
up than see Civil War yeah but but I'll
stress with this great sorting that's
happening it's entirely possible we do
see the Country Split Along on hard
lines you know we're definitely not
going to see Civil War because War has
happened when you've got a lot of young
men and our population structure uh will
not support a war you know um there's
just not enough cannon fodder Neil
Stevenson a great science fiction author
one of my favorites um has had the sort
of future history of loosely linked
books and uh he has sort of you know
crazy red tribe rural areas and crazy
blue tribe rural areas and somehow they
coexist and I think that sometimes
governments just get exhausted and don't
have the political will to enforce
hegemony and um you know I think that
we're to some degree stepping into that
world right now um where we get soft
succession that you know maybe the tax
dollars keep filing back to Washington
and you know maybe the bomber bases
still sit here but we're not going to
listen to laws we don't want to and
we've seen that with marijuana
legalization at the state level thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to see
the full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full all bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time